I'm very excited to be here tonight to  present the award for Best Performance  by an actor in a supporting role and the  nominees are Jeff Bridges in The  Contender Willem Dafoe in shadow of the  vampire Benicio del Toro in traffic  Albert Finney in Erin Brockovich  Joaquin Phoenix in Gladiator  and the Oscar goes to Benicio del Toro  this is the first  and nominations for Benicio del Toro  well thank you thank you  I'd like to thank the members of the  Academy  I'd also like to thank Steven Soderbergh  Laura Bigford Ed's Wieck marshal Rick  and Eileen everyone at USA films and  that I also like to dedicate this to to  locations where we shot this film we  went from Washington DC all the way to  San Diego California  I'd like to dedicate this to the people  of Nogales Arizona and Nogales Mexico  thank you